you know really good uh kind of mix up
tonight with the uh
with the calls obviously we had to do
some different things without devonte
and then without allen
without mercedes uh but i thought uh you
know a nice plan and then we executed
really well
and i thought a number of guys who
stepped up and played really well jamal
williams
uh you know to have almost 100 yards
receiving uh was uh fantastic
aaron jones getting involved in the run
the pass game
obviously again he's just such a
consistent solid player in so many
different areas
love love him as a teammate in person
obviously confidence has never wavered
but i do feel really good in the offense
i feel like matt and i are really on the
same page
not that we weren't last year i just
feel like we're doing doing so much more
you know i think i think the creativity
and the aggressive nature has been
has been really good we've known when to
push when to pull back
and i think as a team you never know
what the team's gonna look like um
every year you have to have kind of a
new rally and cry a new uh new mantras
new slogans and
sayings new things that happened new
dances you look at them all for that
stuff but
but i like the way we're starting out
we've had to win with offense
you know a couple games and the defense
really settled and did a nice job
tonight
we still owe them probably four or five
games from last year so we're
trying to pay them back for the early
enzymes
even with no legs i still think you
could have won
aaron rodgers i love you so much i don't
sing that song for my own personal
uh just fun oh aaron rodgers
[Music]
i have a man crush on him
i i still can't believe he let you touch
him
i don't know you know there was that
there was a stalker where he's finally
like fine
just get one touch all right and get
away
how about that clip of us in the same
room what the hell was that
right i mean that's weird i know damn i
don't
i wish i could just throw my right arm
out here and hit you in the chest
it would make me feel better i'd feel
more comfortable i don't care about
getting hit in the chest it's the claw
it's that big giant meat hook of yours
it's like the claw with with
flesh on it where it just and it's
inevitably gonna unlike the actual
machine that never works
yeah right the sims claw actually works
it does
all right aaron rodgers and the packers
beat the falcons last night 30-16 let me
just say this before i forget
last year the jets and the falcons
finished a combined 12-4 down the
stretch they're combined
oh and eight so i am no longer going to
mention carryover
as a factor in what a team's going to do
the next year that theory has been
forever retired chris
okay that's good you're right those two
teams have proven it wrong and
you know hey we can still talk about the
the packers we thought maybe they'd have
like a a carryover or a letdown almost
for for how they ended last year we
didn't think they did a lot in the off
season to improve their football team
but holy cow i mean holy cow
i mean first off i i just aaron rodgers
is
freaking amazing i don't know any other
way to say it he is the green bay
packers
and what he does and the strength of
their football team is all around aaron
rodgers
it really is first of all tanyan
williams valdez scanling
shepard holy cow what weapons around him
in the past game
most of the people in america have never
even heard those last names
but it doesn't matter aaron rodgers just
tears it up and dices everybody up
they just have moments on the offensive
side of the ball
and i thought brian griese did a good
job of kind of explaining this last
night where
their execution and his ability to
diagnose plays
and their aggressive nature of like what
he said about the offense right now
it almost makes them unstoppable in
certain moments i know they have
you know hey a series here in a series
here that doesn't go well
but their ability to just kind of put
two
three drives together in a row and just
rip off plays one after another
uh it really is amazing to me and of
course that starts with rogers and
leflore and everything they got going on
on the meetings during the week yeah and
here's the thing too this is a team
that easily could have a letdown yeah
last night
easily easily against the falcons and
when the packers played the lions at
lambeau field with no one there they
fell behind 14-3 aaron jones told me
after the game it did take him a while
to get
going with no one there they they were
fine
last night i mean yeah yeah they should
have been up maybe a little more early
on they had the goal line stand where
they didn't score when it was seven
nothing but
but still this is this is
what happens when a good team takes care
of its business
even against the bad team you don't see
a good team let down against a bad team
and get surprised and get stunned and
get upset
they keep taking care of business they
keep checking off boxes and it helps to
have aaron rodgers it doesn't matter if
devonte adams doesn't play it doesn't
matter
if alan lazard had had core muscle
surgery and he's out for a while whoever
is out there is getting it done and last
night was robert tonyan's night six
catches three touchdowns 98 yards
from a tight end and you know if this
guy emerges
if this isn't a one-week thing this is
the thing that
that they always seem to be searching
for but never have remember jeremiah
finley they thought they had it with him
that didn't work out
yeah jared cook for a little while he
made that great catch in the playoff win
over dallas and then wanted too much
money and the packers let him walk away
but that pass catching tight end you
know if your receivers aren't going to
be at the highest possible level if your
secret weapon
is a robert tonyan they thought you know
they thought jimmy graham
no right if tonyan can be that guy
that that changes everything for aaron
rodgers doesn't it did he give him that
weapon over the middle
right i agreed mike i mean if they can
have one more guy emerge that's what
thinks about alan lazard kind of getting
hurt and all that because he was kind of
emerging as a
a real bona fide you know target for
rogers a guy that the offense could
count on and we know devonte adams will
be back and marquez
you know valdez scandling you know he's
continuing to do a good job
but with the way they want to run the
ball and then they get a presence out of
their tight end
you know it'll be let's say the poor
man's george kittle factor
it really will be running the ball great
drop back pass game of course rogers
throwing strikes everywhere
but their play-action pass game is
what's really took taken off ever since
lefleur got there
and like roger says it's more ideas
they're doing more things off of that
and yes between tanyan and even the the
second year kid jay sternberger who you
know didn't really do much last night
they got some talent there to where i
hope that continues to develop
because they need to continue to infuse
people in the offense that make a
defense think like oh he's on the field
they lack that that's what concerns me
is when they play the really good
defenses that oh man devonte adams is
taken away and then
oh we're having a hard time running and
what happens after that that that's what
scares me about green bay but
yeah tonya looked the part he really did
and uh
that'll be nice off their run game let
me let me
just blurt out something that i'm
thinking as i reflect on last night
because
the second game you know it felt a
little flat
because the first game was more exciting
and of course it was the falcons if
it was just packers falcons last night
starting at the normal time of 8 15.
it would have been just kind of like
okay this is one of those games where
you can't flex out on monday night
especially week four you just watch the
game and be glad that football's on tv
what do you think about a monday night
doubleheader as a regular
habit where there is overlap you can't
do
two standalone games back to back people
aren't gonna stay up until one am you
can't do
seven do that to me but what if you what
if you do seven and nine though what
i mean we're in a two-screen world
except for you apparently
but we you know i mean we can we can
watch
two games at once we can we can do that
as one game ends and the next one gets
started right do you start it's
if you have a hour window of nfl
football with that one hour overlap
every monday night
it would isn't that good take one of the
one o'clock games out that you don't get
to focus on anyway
drop it into the early spot you got a
game at seven you got a game at nine
you've got an hour of overlap
yeah they may have discovered plutonium
by accident listen i i enjoyed last
night i
i was a little worried going like damn i
just want to watch one game at a time
and do that
but you know you're it kind of
overlapped in a nice way to where
yeah i'm focusing on the end of the
chiefs patriots game
you know with keeping an eye on packers
atlanta and that's
early phase i don't need to know like
every play d you know what i mean so
it did have a nice feel to it i agree i
i mean i would be more in favor of six
and eight o'clock and rather than seven
and nine
but i i uh i found it kind of fun too
mike
because you know you get to the end of
that patriots chiefs game it's at the
end of the game
and the other one's just kicking off to
where okay yeah you guys get warmed up
this one's real good and juicy at the
end and then you know you can kind of
take over from there
um yeah maybe it's something they think
about just a thought
because i look you and i like as many
games that we can focus on
at once because that that sunday one
o'clock eastern
cluster of eight or nine ten games it's
impossible to keep track of everything
and this and that to the extent that
that live
professional football pulls an audience
together like nothing else
why not have a five-hour window every
monday night instead of a three-hour
window
just something to consider all right
aaron rodgers late in the game oh boy
oh my gosh i almost had a heart attack
yeah
yeah but what almost your second heart
attack in two days your boy blue
goes down on sunday with the shoulder
and you're all petrified
you're ready to fly to las vegas and and
leave nbc sports group headquarters in
connecticut to go check on josh allen
and then that that weird left leg step
where
it was that you know that that that
thing that leg just gets caught
and like when you miss the step right on
the stair like it just doesn't it hyper
extends a little bit
here's aaron rodgers after the game
talking about what
seemed to be an injury scare but
apparently wasn't
i'm fine i was like i said after the
game
all in all probably more embarrassed
than
than injured um you know
if we had to play this week thursday
i'd play sunday i'd play so
i'm fine tuesday i'd play next time
you know you know i i i look
i don't know what kind of a poker face
he has i i just caught a little whiff of
something there
what as he was as he was downplaying it
i don't know
i don't know he i i'm just telling you
i'm just telling you i look and this is
this is poker face reading
that just the way that he delivered that
right i think he's trying a little too
hard to convince everybody he's okay
yeah well you're not johnny the card
shark so i'm not sure about your poker
face
you don't know that yeah
bring your money and or whatever else
you would uh put on the table in lieu of
money
well yeah i might bring that it might
confuse you while you're playing cards
though you might not know what's going
on with all that in the air
all right but um i i
i uh i was concerned i mean that's never
a good look to like to what you're
saying i mean
he jammed his left leg and and hyper
extended it
uh i don't think he's hurt i think it's
probably gonna be sore
i do think what he said there i think
he's embarrassed
i really do i think you know he listen
he he's the man
you heard him last year with mike tarico
and sunday night football was that last
year or two years ago when he still
i still want to be houdini remember he
made that comment
you know he doesn't give a damn that
he's 36 he still expects to pull off
these plays like he's 27
still and make rogers magic and you know
that's not gonna be able to happen
forever i hope he knows that
he can still make magic in the pocket
and be houdini that way but
yeah him flipping field and reversing
you know reversing out of the pocket and
all that
those days are getting to the end here
at some point at 36 years old going on
37
but i do i think he was embarrassed
because i think he thinks he's
you know he's aaron rodgers and he walks
on water like your mike zimmer said from
the minnesota vikings
yeah and he's still got it although when
you see a moment like that you wonder is
that the first of
several is this the start of maybe the
decline you know you said it yourself
last year you saw
dip yeah a little bit in his play yeah
this year he's doing pretty good and
they're getting it done
and and and look to the extent that that
mark
i think mark murphy is the ultimate
wizard when it comes to manipulation
because remember last year the reaction
after the
bleacher report story about the acrimony
and the dysfunction between aaron
rodgers and mike mccarthy
mark murphy's like this could be good to
the extent that it
pisses some people off maybe this is
good maybe
using the first round draft pick on a
quarterback instead of a receiver to the
extent that it pissed a certain person
who wears number 12 off
maybe that's good i i look at where they
are yeah i do you know that they
they right now look at the nfc right
saints
not dominant i mean it's the seahawks
it's the packers
and it's tails don't rule out the
buccaneers exactly
i think you're right tampa's the third
best team for me tampa's gonna
when i turn on tampa film yesterday i go
uh oh
they look kind of like they're getting
scary good that's what i look like with
tampa
you know and i don't think tampa two
weeks tampa can beat green bay in
seattle there's no doubt
their offense weapons their defense that
d-line i mean we know green bay and
seattle's defense are nothing special
so that i mean i i i'm i'm with you
there
but roger's to your fat your point with
mark murphy and everything like that
i mean it's it's freaking laser beams
everywhere right now and it's no second
guessing himself and that's the thing
again that just jumps out to me
more than anything about his specific
play is how many times last night he
dropped back
and in years past he would have gone oh
that's a little too tight of a throw i'm
gonna dance around
and make rogers magic and i'll find
somebody more open that's not quite as
risky
this year he's going oh he's open by
three inches
i'm aaron rodgers i'm going to throw a
freaking laser in there and hit him
right in the chest
and i just see that more and more where
he's just confident in the play design
he's trusting the routes of the
receivers and what they're doing
and it's allowing him to just let it go
because he goes
i know they're going to be where they're
supposed to be and i think that's been a
big part of their offense this year a
big improvement
last monday night's game featured a
couple of former league mvps
the early game last night should have
fortune
featured a couple of few of uh former
league mvps
the late game also did you just don't
think about matt ryan as a former nfl
mvp
and the falcons are falling apart and
here's ryan after the game talking about
uh
that one and basically the way things
have gone all year for the falcons
well you know we got 12 games to go and
six of them are in division and so we've
got some
definite ground to make up uh we've got
to find a way to
you know to make it up quick and so um
can't feel sorry for yourself you know
we're in the position we're in because
of what we've done
but you know we're also the people who
can correct it and so
uh that's got to be the focus we've got
to get a win next week we've got to find
a way to get it done versus a tough
division opponent
now here's the problem they're all alone
in last place in the nfc south two games
behind
both the saints and the panthers the
rise of the panthers
is what complicates this process
dramatically for the falcons
because if they got any designs on
getting to the top of the division and
come on that ship has sailed oh yeah
they got to jump three teams to get
there their best hope now
is just get a win stop the bleeding and
see if there's a way that you can
connect the dots
to get yourself into the seventh season
that's it and yeah the upcoming schedule
has winnable games but you got to win
one game before you can call any other
game winnable
yeah that's right i mean there's nothing
in there there's nobody in football
right now
other than the jets that i'm gonna sit
there and go
atlanta will beat them they'll beat them
for sure okay maybe the giants i don't
even know
i'd be probably maybe think a little bit
about the giants but
atlanta's no shoeing for anybody in
football i mean none
well what is there to look at last night
and go oh
i i see it they're this close what what
is it
the crappy secondary you know lack of a
pass rush
no toughness on offense or is it just
you know matt ryan have
always having to make plays and you know
do all those type of things but their
defense gives them no chance
they don't have a running game julio's
banged up consistently
and it always just falls on to matt ryan
to be like oh all right matt you know
you just you just gotta throw for 390
and four touchdowns this week and maybe
we can win
and it's just it's not realistic there's
no team there there's just a few
individuals
with you know just okay around him
and with with bill o'brien being out in
houston again we're going to talk about
that coming up but i think we'll lump in
some of these other coaches because
chris i wonder if
o'brien is the first domino and it gets
other
say yeah screw it let's let's let's move
on let's make our change and let's move
forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports